mon gras durs et là alors c'est pas du
tout je voudrais dire que tu es là en
plus et c'est ça que je kiffe chez toi
et là parce que n'est pas là pour faire
de la promo pour ton album tu es pas là
pour faire de la promo pour un concert
t'es pas là pour faire de la promo
pourtant blouson et je comprends il est
beau il est beau soit il très beau frère
mais non tu es là pour un truc beaucoup
internet je voulais juste vous dire un
petit mot encore soit parce que c'est
vrai qu'on en entend peu parler on est
la seule chaîne à le faire est la seule
émission
tous voudraient nous parler d'un autre
truc parce qu'il ya un rassemblement qui
se passe je crois à cette semaine voilà
il ya une manifestation
oui dont qui a été fait par le biais du
quoditien exactement claudie qui est
fabuleux et qui vient nous voir dans
vendredi dont dix huit avec qui j'étais
au téléphone tout à l'heure
ouais donc c'est en concernant l'
esclavage esclave à genlis guise ya en
ce moment et voilà des gens qui vendent
des êtres humains
donc c'est un crime contre l'humanité a
pas énormément de deux personnes qui en
parle qui relaie le truc et c'est vrai
que la gale piste premier mise du
gouvernement libyen qui a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur les cas
d'esclavagé et c'est vrai que graduée en
on en a parlé avec à m sila le lundi on
en reparle aujourd'hui et on en parle
voilà pour que le gouvernement français
aussi essayer de se mobiliser et essayer
de faire quelque chose j'ai entendu que
aujourd'hui une réunion et à moins
grands qui va saisir excellent
exactement ils vont commencer à vous
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
exactement donc c'est déjà bien déjà ça
commence à bouger je sais que c'est
hyper important pour toi moi et
franchement avait déjà c'est même pas
une histoire de dunes d'une race contre
une race et l'être humain est un être
humain trop court il attend et ça c'est
grave de savoir qu'en 2017
il ya des choses que cet espace
personnes qui vendent des hommes aux 200
francs pour trois cent des gens qui qui
sont là qui fuit leur pays pour essayer
d'aller en europe donc la libye en fait
c'est un max migratoires donc c'est à
300 km de l'italie et on leur vend du
rêve c'est qu'ils vont aller en euros
exactement et c'est insupportable ce qui
se passe là-bas et merci à gras dur
d'être venu vous dire
exceptionnel et se dit qu'on refera le
passé mais ça donc par écrit messages
comme ça voilà quand on pourra et à m
sila on avait passé un lundi et merci